When It: Chapter Two hits theaters, there
will be blood… lots and lots of blood.
Director Andy Muschietti and star Jessica
Chastain revealed to the crowd at San Diego
Comic-Con that one set piece features more
fake blood than you've ever seen in a single
scene.
We're talking 4,500 gallons.
In an interview with Entertainment Weekly,
Chastain opened up about filming the gory
moment:
"What was it like shooting the blood scene?
It was… gross.
And… but it was fine."
Was it, though?
You may recall that in It: Chapter One, young
Beverly has a messy encounter with the evil,
shape-shifting entity which usually appears
as Pennywise the Dancing Clown.
While inside the bathroom of her father's
house, she investigates the source of mysterious
childrens' voices coming from the drain in
the sink.
"Beverly…"
As soon as she gets close enough, the plumbing
backs up a little bit as plumbing tends to
do.
But then, the sink unleashes an unearthly
geyser of blood, as plumbing generally tends
not to do.
The supernatural skirmish leaves the screaming
girl soaked in gore.
And she's beyond confused when her father
can't see the mess at all.
"What blood?"
In a brief moment from the final trailer of
It: Chapter Two, adult Beverly appears in
a bathroom covered in blood and we strongly
suspect it's a glimpse of the scene everyone's
talking about.
While speaking at San Diego Comic-Con, Chastain
revealed that she told Muschietti to go buck-wild
with buckets blood.
According to We Got This Covered, she said:
"I was like, ‘No, if we’re going to do
it, let’s do it.’
I love horror films, I love Carrie, and I
said, ‘Let’s make Carrie on steroids.’
And that’s what we did and it literally
tortured me because I didn’t realize that
it would be that way the whole movie."
We're not sure exactly what Chastain means
by "the whole movie."
Judging by the trailers, she does not, in
fact, spend the entire film bathing in blood.
We think she means the film effectively doubles
down on the gore in It: Chapter One.
If so, we're totally here for It.
"Hello."
Muschietti provided the 4,500 gallon figure,
which may or may not be a record.
It was widely reported that director Fede
Alvarez used no less than 50,000 gallons of
fake blood for the final, climactic scene
of 2013's Evil Dead.
Time will tell which scene is the bloodiest
of the two.
In any event, Muschietti's statement lines
up with remarks Chastain made during an appearance
on The Tonight Show with Jimmy Fallon.
"There's a scene that someone said on set
that it's the most blood that's ever been
in a horror film — in a scene."
It also squares with something It: Chapter
Two screenwriter Gary Dauberman told The Hollywood
Reporter:
"I know the particular scene you're talking
about, and there's no way to do it without
a ton of blood.
Knowing Andy, he always takes things and multiplies
them, which is what you want out of your director.
It's pretty incredible."
The screenwriter also revealed that he's seen
the finished film, and he loved the end result:
"I’m very, very happy and I’m very, very
proud.
I don’t know if you can hear the joy in
my voice as I try not to answer this question,
but I’m very excited for everyone to see
it.
As a very, very anxious person, I have no
anxiety about that movie whatsoever."
He's not the only one who's excited.
Both It films are based on the 1986 novel
written by Stephen King, who recently took
to Twitter to share his own opinion of the
movie:
"Looking forward to IT CHAPTER 2?
You should be.
I've seen it, and it's terrific."
If that's not enough to pump you up, we don't
know what is.
Be sure to mark your calendars: It: Chapter
Two floats into theaters on September 6th,
2019.
"You'll float too.
You'll float too.
You'll float too…"
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
films are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.